depuis plusieurs années maintenant les
Italiens ont pris le Tureau par les
cornes si j'ose dire en prenant des
mesures drastiques c'est ainsi que la
circulation des voitures sera interdite
à Florence et surtout à Rome pendant 5h
demain seul les transports publics les
ambulances les deux roues mais aussi les
voitures muni de peau catalytique
pourront circuler à Paris on n est pas
encore là mais la grogne monte aussi
sûrement que le niveau de la pollution
reportage valer gager José
blanclapierre qualité de l'air médiocre
depuis lundi Paris suff
la pollution s'est un peu résorbée mais
reste préoccupante aucune mesure de
restriction de la circulation n'a encore
été prise en région parisienne devant
cette école du 11e arrondissement les
parents d'élèves ne cachent pas leur
lassitude ils sont toujours malades la
gorge le nez les yeux moi j'habite dans
le Nord ils ont jamais été malades comme
ils sont malades ici le problème
essentiel est qu'une fois de plus les
Français ont été alertés trop tard après
le dépassement des seuils de pollution
un peu prise de de cours Corine le page
le ministre de l'Environnement a
convoqué aujourd'hui les deux préfets
parisiens il y a effectivement une
situation de très grande urgence que
nous avons à gérer nous essayons de la
gérer au mieux et ce à quoi je suis très
attentive c'est que très vite et c'est
ce que j'ai demandé au préfet les plans
d'urgence puissent être établis pour
nous permettre de réagir dans les mois
qui viennent les semaines qui viennent
ou les jours qui viennent si la
situation le justifie car 15 jours après
son adoption la loi sur l'air montre
peut-être déjà ses faiblesses même si
les décrets d'application n'ont pas
encore été publiés en cas de crise tout
repose sur la bonne volonté des préfets
à eux de mettre en œuvre ces fameux plan
d'urgence comme il n'y a pas de
directive contraignante si on lit bien
le texte il est évident que selon les
régions les préfet et leur état d'esprit
face à la circulation automobile ces
gens-là pourront faire à peu près ce
qu'ils veulent c'està-dire beaucoup
s'ils le veulent et très peu pour
réduire la circulation automobile et
donc la pollution de l'air à Lyon le
préfet n'a pas hésit à prendre pour la
première fois des mesures coercitives à
Paris même si pour l'instant la
situation n'est pas aussi grave le
préfet reste
silencieux notre